Good morning Togo.
Good morning guys.
We've been back home for a few weeks.
We've been working nonstop and it is time
to work again but this morning I don't really feel
like making breakfast so I'm thinking about taking
you guys to the best most amazing breakfast spot.
It's not the best breakfast spot - it's
just the best restaurant in the world.
And I think we need to take Togo and Chibi.
Togo.
Chibi.
Restaurant.
Nevermind.
Who's that.
Hey Jaques, good morning.
Good morning.
Uh, what did I
hear about the best restaurant in the world?
Do you want to go to the best restaurant in the
world for some breakfast?
Yes!
Alright let's go, let's go.
He knows exactly where we're going.
I just need to check in with Nikita.
Yes, hi, good morning.
Good morning.
I don't feel like breakfast.
We didn't even make up the bed yet.
No, we haven't so I'm just quickly...
How about we go to the best
restaurant in the world?
Oh yes, Nevermind.
I'm in.
Let's go.
We didn't even get ready yet.
I still need to do my hair.
We need to make up the bed.
Do a few things.
Get Togo and Chibi.
And then we're going to go to the
most amazing restaurant in the world.
So fluffy Chibi.
You're too fluffy.
Too much fluff.
Jaques do you
want to take Togo?
Then I'll drive.
Man, they love going out.
They can't wait,
huh Togo Chibi?
Nevermind.
They know what's waiting.
Alright, let's go.
Okay, let's go let's go let's go go go.
Too fat Togo. Go go go go you can do it.
Alright, sorry, let's help him.
Oh alright, alright, everybody's in.
Here we go.
Let's go.
So the awesome thing about Nevermind
is that you can take your pets with.
Of course you need to sit outside.
And they need to be on a leash.
Right.
But the the most amazing thing is not
just the food, I mean the food, that's incredible,
but it is all about the location and the people.
And the atmosphere.
Right.
So we live in a place called St. Francis Bay
and just a few kilometers is Cape St. Francis.
Beautiful houses, beautiful people.
Down to earth people.
And so it's the whole atmosphere -
so this place clicks all the boxes.
I've been to a lot of places even eating in
front of a master chef in Japan - sushi - but
this place beats all of the places I've
ever been to almost over 20 countries.
Hello, Chibi.
He's just lying there.
He actually gets carsick Daniel.
Oh... little Chibi.
But it's not too far.
Yeah.
Daniel you're driving rough.
No no no but look here everything is
in the road there's like chickens...
there's people... there's dogs.
There's dogs.
Other dogs ... Togo might
not like that if you see them.
And then there's pigs around
here as well that we saw.
Togo you excited, huh?
So this is Cape St. Francis everyone.
Togo....
He's way too excited.
Yeah.
Man this is beautiful.
This is it.
Alright, we're here.
But the dogs, they've got too
much energy, so we're just going to walk them.
We're going to put the drone up in the air.
Jaque's going to do that for us.
And we're going to show you
how beautiful this place really is.
Now I don't think Togo and Chibi - they
saw the Drone yet - and when this thing lifts
off I think they're going to get a big scare.
Togo's running away.
Chibi is not.
Hey, Chibi's just like .. this is cool.
He doesn't like it at all.
He's hiding.
What's it Togo.
It's up in the air now.
Togo doesn't like it at all.
Don't worry, buddy, don't worry.
Let's go,
Let's go.
We're going to walk.
Wow, check out all these shells.
So many.
I mean it's just there's just so many here.
Wow.
What is that?
So we call this
in Africans Pampoenkie (Sea Urchin) which
if you directly translate it is pumpkin.
Wow.
Now if you do
come here please don't take all these shells away,
because if everybody comes and everybody takes a
lot of shells at the end there's nothing left.
And that's what happened around the rest of
the world.
Wow nice.
South Africa really is a beautiful country.
Everywhere you look - you see these flowers
in purple yellow and then the
beautiful ocean of course.
So what I feel like when I live here
in South Africa is - it's more rugged.
It's more like old country, you know?
Like the old world where it's untouched.
And I love it.
Wow look at these beautiful waves.
There's a big wave coming.
Wow, I'm going to get wet.
It can be very dangerous
so we don't want to get closer.
We actually want to go back now.
It's getting high tide and there's
a lot of fishermen who die because
they take chances with Mother Nature.
I'm not one of those fishermen and today
I'm not fishing.
Let's go back.
These small legs are tired now.
Shame Chibi, are you tired?
Yeah, so Togo ... let's go this way.
I think that was a good idea.
Their energy is out so now it'll be
easier to go sit down and have breakfast.
And then you guys... see the
lighthouse there behind me?
You can book a night and you can sleep there.
They can bring the food to you as well.
It's quite special.
We'll show you what it looks like.
Look at this.
You are now at the Southeastern
most tip of Africa - Seal Point.
Cape St. Francis.
Man, there's some
beautiful fish that you can catch from here.
The whole Garden Route up until Cape Town.
And I think that should be our next vlog.
Catching some tuna in South Africa.
They get big.
Yellow tail tuna.
Nikita, you're going to stay here with the dogs?
Yes.
I have to stay outside with the dogs.
Enjoy.
Alright, bye.
Bye.
1878.
It's quite old.
Oh nice.
Oh so this is the place where
they bring you the food, where you sleep.
This is the place where you can sleep.
Very nice.
Look how old it is Jaques.
Cool.
Like the aesthetic.
Over here you have a kitchen.
Wow look at this old stove.
That's so cool.
Got a fridge over
there, washing area.
Wow, this is nice.
Ooh look at the shower - check this out.
You guys want to come here, I'll add all the
links for you in the video description down below.
And then, ooh look at this... this is quite nice,
huh?
Alright.
Ooo this is a nice view.
Oh awesome, yeah you can see the waves there.
Nice.
Jaques, I think you can go.
(laughter)
OK, let's try that again.
Alright Jaques I'll sit here - you can go.
So if you do come here remember just to put
this in there so you didn't fall through.
So many videos where Daniel falls.
Yeah okay that's comfortable.
Ooo, you can hear the echo.
Echo.
Hooooo
And this is where you go up the lighthouse.
It's actually a bit scary.
Construction began 17 March 1876.
Oh just the door opening... hear that echo?
It's kind of scary.
Yeah, I'm not going to talk a lot
because the echo is a bit crazy.
There's a whale as well Jaques.
I don't think you guys can see it
with the GoPro because it's too far.
We'll have to use the drone.
Yes.
Let's go up.
Be careful if you walk here.
Almost.
Whoa, this is so small.
Wow, they've got some history.
Lighthouse keeper in St. Francis
from 1975 to 1987.
That's Andries.
Lighthouses saved a lot of lives.
What they do is they give out the light every
few seconds and every lighthouse is different.
In different countries so when people are on
ships they count when they see the light maybe
after 3 seconds every time other countries maybe
6 seconds and then they know, alright, they
are now close to South Africa, for example.
Very interesting how lighthouses work.
Very cool.
Oooh we're not there yet.
Man its so steep.
Ah you made it.
There's more.
Okay look at how steep this is.
Not fun.
Yeah it's quite high up already.
I think it's the last little bit.
You go first.
You don't like heights.
No, I can just imagine what it's
going to look like at the top.
So I might stay inside.
OK, its even steeper.
Here we go.
You can bump your head easily.
This is quite nice.
Yeah.
Maybe pass through here.
Okay here we are.
Oh, here's the generators and the gear
that's sending the light I believe.
Look at the view Jaques.
Wow.
Man.
Beautiful, huh.
That is amazing.
There's the restaurant down there.
This is why it's so beautiful.
You've got the ocean there and
you've got it there as well.
I'm kind of shaking a bit looking down.
Especially I'm trying to look there.
Look at those people down there.
Yeah it's pretty high.
It's quite hot.
Yeah.
I'm a bit more stressed about the
way down than I was with the way up.
This is the light.
Man, this is is intense.
And this is why as reborn Christians
you know we should be the light of the
world not hiding sharing the gospel
in boldness in truth and in love.
Too many Christians out there are afraid.
And they're not a sweet
smelling aroma to other people.
Some Christians are very judgmental.
We should be the light of the world.
Light attracts and brings people out of darkness.
This is why we have the merch
of the lighthouse as well.
You can get it ... check it
out in the video description.
I like the smell in here.
Watch your head Jaques.
Chibi.... Togo.
Let's go let's go let's go... this way.
Oh look at this.
Hm morning.
Morning, hello good morning.
Good morning.
How are you?
Good, and you?
Good to see you.
I told you the people were friendly here.
Hot capuccino?
Yes, thank you.
What about my hug?
Thank you.
You already know we want cappuccino, right?
They've got the best coffee.
Alright, let's go sit down here.
The cool thing is they have these spots here
where you can just keep your dogs close to you.
There we go.
Some water.
This thing is really cool if you have pets.
Look at that.
The water just comes like
that if you press the button.
Oh okay wait wait to go.
Just wait a bit... there we go.
And if there's a little bit left
over you just press the button again and
you do that and it all slowly goes back in.
Alright, there you go.
Thank you.
The best coffee in the world.
There we go.
Thank you so much.
Thank you enjoy.
Ohhh, now the day can start with good coffee.
My goodness.
So the menu ... man everything here is unique.
You won't get this really at other places.
The normal general restaurants.
Wow.
And the the problem with that is
you never know what to choose.
Let me show you.
It's Italian eggs.
Eggs your way.
Green eggs and ham
Oooh Nikita you like this.
Yes, I love green eggs and ham.
Olive oil crispy fried eggs - gabagool,
wow that's I don't even how know I
don't even know how to pronounce that.
chimichuri, parmesan, and fresh sourdough.
Oooh salmon tartar, I might choose that.
Peas please.
This is interesting.
Sourdough toast, peas, avocado
riccota, pesto, poached egg.
Tomatoes on toast, mushrooms on toast,
sourdough blueberry, oh my goodness.
You see why I like this place.
What are you guys going to choose?
I think today because it's summer so
I'm going to go for a granola bowl.
Oooh.
Jaques, I think the stuff that I can pronounce.
Maybe eggs.
Yeah, I still need to check.
Are you guys ready to order or not yet?
Yes.
Yes, I am good.
You guys as well?
Yeah.
I'm going to take the peas please.
You don't have the.. anymore?
His favorite.
And how do you like your portion?
Medium.
Medium, yeah I like it tasty.
I'm going to have the granola bowl.
Granola bowl?
Yes.
Thank you.
For you sir?
I will take green eggs and ham.
Eggs soft please.
Soft?
Please.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
One thing I want to quickly tell you guys is
you can't feel the wind just on your skin .. you
can't feel the weather... you can't feel anything
when we just show you the camera but just know
and trust us that the atmosphere here is perfect.
And that it is peaceful.
That's what you find here.
Peaceful.
And then the good food.
That's the bonus.
Is the bonus, yeah.
Yeah, the location is beautiful.
It's all about the location.
We've got the sea on this side.
We've got the sea on the other side.
And then there are whales here as
well that you can always watch.
Oh that's beautiful.
And we are not paying to do this - yes this
is not a sponsored video at all - we just,
we just really wanted to share with
you guys the excellence of this place
in every aspect.
Like Daniel said.
Best food I've ever had.
Yeah.
A little bit of peace before
we have to go back to work.
Yeah.
Yes.
That's over here.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Oh wow, thank you.
Very nice.
For your bread sir.
Yes please thank and also a Coke.
Alright thank you so much.
Peas please.
Oh my goodness I've had
that before and it's great.
Nikita, ooh nice looks so awesome.
Hey Jaques what do you have?
This is ham and eggs.
And it looks great.
Man, this is not normal ham and eggs.
No, this is Nevermind ham
and eggs.
Smile.
Here we go.
Coke lights.
Thank you.
Enjoy.
Thank you so much for the light side.
For the light side of life.
This is awesome.
I think we need to pray.
Yes please.
Father thank you so much
for this little time together here with Jaques and
Nikita would you please bless the food in Jesus'
name we pray, amen.
Amen.
Let's dig in.
I think if summer would have tasted like
something it would have tasted like this.
That looks like summer.
Fresh and summery and light.
It's great.
I love ham.
And I love Nevermind ham even more.
Hammmm.
How's that?
Togo?
I think Togo is hungry Nikita.
Does he want us... to give him a snacky?
Yeah.
Sit.
Oh so good.
So Nikita you switched around
a bit huh because of the sun?
A bit because the sun is just too hot.
Oh yeah oh there's a big dog coming over there.
Helloo.
Is he friendly?
Can I pet him?
Yeah.
Name's Daisy.
Hey hello.
It's a big dog Togo, huh?
That's a big dog.
You want to climb on, huh?
Okay alright alright alright there we go.
There we go.
Is that better.
Sit.
Chibi is noticing the big dogs.
Just want to show you guys the vibe inside.
This is quite special.
And then, this is where these amazing
guys are preparing the best food.
How are you guys doing?
Doing well sir.
All good all good.
Whoaa, venison, right?
Yeah, yeah.
This is what we got from a hunt.
So we do some hunting.
They go hunting for like
venison every few months and then we have like
a stock pile that we have left in our freezer.
Nice.
So you guys will
see that the menu at night when you come here
is totally different from the breakfast menu.
Maybe I need to show you.
As you can see it's evening
now and a lot has changed.
Look at those (Afrikaans).
Now they're preparing different food here.
So it's only me and Jaques.
Nikita, she had to do some work.
So I'm just going to show you
the vibe here at evening.
This is a nice private spot
if you want to sit here and eat and have some
privacy and then also a nice fire over here.
For Table 43 please.
You guys remember the venison from earlier today?
It is ready.
I want to eat this for the rest of my life.
Just look at that.
Perfect.
Perfectly medium rare.
Wow, that was amazing.
It's a shame Nikita couldn't
join us because she had meetings but look
how beautiful the lighthouse is at night.
Alright, back home.
Togo Chibi.
Togo
Hello hello hello
buddy hello Chibi.
Hello.
Guys it's been amazing.
We're back home.
Jaques, how was that meat?
Oh man that was amazing.
Best steak I've had.
Yeah, I have to agree but
you know, being next to the ocean today
it made me want to go fishing for tuna.
That sounds great.
So I think, the next video,
that's what we're going to do.
But first up we need to work a few
weeks and then we're going to go fishing.
So if you haven't subscribed yet please
do so you won't miss that video.
And always remember... life is short,
so don't waste yours.
Cheers guys.